what do you got there?
I didn't think I'd see this again.
why don't you hang on to that.
welcome back everyone hopefully you've
had a chance to see the Mandalorian
finale by now this is going to be my season
2 teaser video setup jon favreau was
talking about what's going to be happening
during season 2 they're almost done
shooting it right now so be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos if
you're brand new to my channel I will
keep doing bonus videos while we wait
for it to come back thankfully we won't
have to wait that long before we
actually get it but I will say cursory
spoiler warning for everything from the
Mandalorian season 1 before we talk
about this I'll just do this top 10
style starting with number 10 obviously
where did Moff Gideon get the darksaber
from and what are they going to do with it
during season 2 because you wouldn't
whip something like that out if you
didn't want it to be a big thing next
season I feel like this is actually one
of the easier questions to answer
because they gave us all the backstory
we need on his character in the history
of the Mandalorian people during the
time period between Episode four a new
hope and Return of the Jedi the period
that they keep referring to as the Great
Purge of the Mandalorian people by the
Empire as stated during the episode moth
Gideon was an is be Imperial security
bureau officer working on Mandalore
during the purge this is probably before
he was promoted to full moff and was
just an admiral or high admiral in the
imperial navy the last known person to
wield the darksaber was Bo Katan Kryze
at the end of Star Wars rebels which
took place one year before a new hope
Bo Katan Kryze if you're not familiar
or you didn't watch Star Wars rebels is
the younger sister of duchess satine
Kryze longtime love interest of obi-wan
Kenobi during the Clone Wars but cara
dune then says Moff gideon was tried for
war crimes implying that he did really
really terrible stuff during the war in
the Mandalorian then implies Moff Gideon
pilfered Mandalorian informational
archives and making this sort of a world
war 2 analogy think of Gideon as being
like one of the during World War
two pilfering famous art and family
heirlooms when they were tearing through
Western Europe so you have to imagine
that the Empire is tearing through
Mandalore trying to get rid of the
Mandalorian people just stealing
treasures left and right from all the
famous families it's not confirmed that
he killed Bo Katan Kryze but it just
implied that at some point he either
captured her or captured their family
home and simply took the darksaber for
himself during that they spent a lot of
time during the episode teasing the idea
of finding other Jedi and
were sensitive people out there people
that might have lightsabers so to
balance the scales of good and evil it
would make sense that they would
introduce something like the darksaber
again through Moff Gideon's character
number nine what is the darksaber where
does it come from so if you're not
familiar with the darksaber is actually
just a regular light saber that was
created by the first Mandalorian that
became a member of the Jedi Order this
was all thousands of years ago after the
great war with the Jedi like during the
episode the armorer told tales of the
history of their wars with the Jedi that
was all taking place during the fall of
the Old Republic which was thousands of
years ago so after that at some point
there was a Mandalorian that became a
Jedi when it came time to make his
lightsaber he made something that was
unique to him in his culture and that
became the darksaber that's why it
looks so unique but it's just a normal
light saber like any other with a
special Kyber crystal that's why it
glows black Dave Filoni is the person
that actually created it special for the
Clone Wars though so he sort of retro
actively included it inside the history
of Star Wars but the first time you
actually saw it in any kind of Star Wars
TV show or story or movie was the Clone
Wars animated series so Dave Filoni in
George Lucas got together and George
Lucas actually came up with the concept
so technically George Lucas is the
reason why the darksaber exists but
that's how it wound up inside the Star
Wars Canon but now in present day
obviously it's been stolen by moth
Gideon so it's kind of being perverted
for that purpose so hopefully at some
point we will see the mando in baby Yoda
take the darksaber back mando got his
jetpack upgrade now the next big upgrade
he needs is a darksaber number 8 though
what is moth Gideon going to do now
standing on the wreckage of his tie
Outlander there that says she meant to
be a bit of an easter egg for Darth
Vader standing on top of his tie fighter
in the previous series
they really are setting him up to be the
Gus fring of the Star Wars universe very
hard to kill very shrewd I think it's
all to the betterment of the series
right now he's probably got some
contingency plan to have more of his men
come pick him up covertly and return him
to his command ship hopefully that winds
up being a Star Destroyer because if
he's going to be some sort of warlord
around the galaxy and he used to be a
mop he probably had a bunch of Star
Destroyers at his command before the
fall of the Empire the series trades on
a lot of plot beats from the original
trilogy - and what happened
after the events of the first movie a
new hope we had Empire Strikes Back
where the Empire struck back kicking the
crap out of the rebellion in fracturing
the core Trinity that doesn't
necessarily mean that season two is
going to have a downer ending like Empire
did but it just means that Moff Gideon's
going to come back with tenfold the power
and the ships so they're all screwed for
leaving him alive at the end of this
episode number seven where the
Mandalorian and baby Yoda going next so
he implied he'd be too busy on his
mission to do regular bounty hunting
work out of Navarro as part of his
mission there's a couple things that he
agreed to do number one find Jedi to
Train baby Yoda and care for him and to
find more members of Yoda's race that
also could care for him in as far as we
know Yoda and gadelle were the only
other two living members of their race
during the prequels in yeah ttle
disappeared after attack of the clones
number six where's Luke Skywalker while
all this is going on and what about his
Jedi Temple that would be a pretty easy
place to go drop off baby Yoda well
you'd think that the Mandalorian would
know more about the Jedi as a matter of
record but the way they talk about them
on the show he doesn't know anything
about the force or about Luke Skywalker
this is all taking place five years
after Return the Jedi so Luke Skywalker
didn't create his new Jedi Temple until
sixteen years after season 1 of the
Mandalorian so as far as we know right
now Luke Skywalker is still busy working
to help stamp out the remnants of the
Empire around the galaxy and solidify
the new republic government number five
this was actually a big question that I
got on my videos will Mark Hamill ever
guest star in a future season is Luke
Skywalker because he's actually pretty
young during the events of the
Mandalorian I think most of us are in
agreement that they're probably not
going to do Luke on the TV show for a
couple reasons
first he's super old right now Mark
Hamill in real life and after Return of
the Jedi Luke Skywalker was only 23
years old so right now during the
Mandalorian which is five years later
he's still only be 28 years old so
number four what about other Jedi
showing up during season two I think
this scene here where the armor tells
him to find more Jedi is just a big
setup and a teaser for them to introduce
other rogue Jedi who survived the purge
during season two maybe somebody we've
seen before like ahsoka maybe a new
character more likely a new character
but I really really do hope they
introduce a live-action version of
ahsoka on one of these Disney
series just for reference though she's
actually still very young during the
events of the mandalorian she'd be in
her early to mid 40s while this is all
going on
so still prime age for any big Hollywood
actress to come be on the show
number three what about that mysterious
gunslinger teaser from the end of
episode 5 they teased it like there was
going to be some huge reveal in the finale
who is this person I talked about it
during my episode 5 video and again
recently but they really really want you
to think that this is going to be Boba
Fett because the special Spurs that he
wears that make that sound when he walks
are the same ones that Boba Fett wears
the fact that this is all happening on
Tatooine five years after Return of the
Jedi the fact that he's wearing a cape
like both of the foot wears and pretty
much every story set around Tatooine
after Return of the Jedi Boba Fett
escapes the Sarlacc pit
so what's the deal why did they tease
this and never pay it off before the end
of season one either wound up being a
deleted scene that they just didn't have
time for or more likely they decided
when they were prepping the finale to
just save the reveal for season two like
okay we don't need to do this right now
we can save this for a big moment in the
future so it's still wide open to theory
crafting about who this is but again Jon
Favreau and Dave floatie really want you
to think this is Boba Fett and if we're
thinking about season two if it's going
to be like the Empire Strikes Back
version of the Mandalorian series like
Moff Gideon comes back with a vengeance
who would he hire but other badass
bounty hunters to go after the child in
the Mandalorian number two what about
new baby Yoda Jedi powers and force
abilities random acts of the force are
sort of their go-to moment in the
series anytime they wanted some big
dramatic twist they just pull a new
force power out of their tool belt given
the stuff we've seen baby Yoda do so far
the next real basic abilities that you
typically saw in the classic trilogy
assuming we're trying more on classic
trilogy references is the Jedi
mind-trick
in number one of course Moff Gideon's
secret cloning plans for baby Yoda that
they never really paid off at the end of
the season he had this whole big speech
in Episode seven about how important
baby Yoda was to him and how the
Mandalorian couldn't even comprehend how
important he was it was pretty clear
what they were setting up from the first
couple of episodes doctor Pershing's
imperial cloning uniform from Kamino
that they wanted to harvest DNA from
baby Yoda to create a new army of
force-sensitive clones that Moff Gideon
would be able to control
kind of got into this during the Clone
Wars animated series where Emperor
Palpatine was trying to steal for
sensitive children brainwashed them as
children to grow up to be his army of
Sith spies that he could just send all
over the galaxy and they'd be this
unstoppable force pretty safe bet that
we're going to find out more about what's
going on with his secret plan
quote-unquote during season two and
hopefully get a better look at the inner
workings of his organization we didn't
really visit any of his home bases or
any of his ships or Star Destroyers that
he might have so for the most part I'm
just assuming that all the other big
characters that weren't confirmed dead
this season will come back to like
Dr. Pershing is prime example there was this other teaser that Jon Favreau dropped it
was the gomorian where he was basically
saying that season two was going to
premiere around the same time next year
the season 1 premiere which means
November but the fact that there's a
gomorian here doesn't necessarily mean
they're going back to Jabba's palace
because obviously he has Gammorean guards
but I'll keep doing bonus videos for
season 2 as we get more information
they're still in the middle of shooting
right now we'll probably get a trailer
either later in the spring maybe by
early summer so leave all your requests
and your big questions in the comments
below and I'll add it to my list of
videos every one click here for my full
Mandalorian episode 8 video and click
here for my new Witcher Netflix episode
videos thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome, I have spoken.